SOT vehicle we're gonna get us a little
pasta hey everybody thanks I'm going to
talk today about robust list decoding of
spherical gaussians so the basic outline
of this talk I'm going to talk a bit
about the problem set up and some sort
of historical development I'm going to
talk about some of the information
theoretic bounds and what we might hope
to achieve I'll then talk about the
basic technique that we that's been
known for a while to get sort of
anything on these kinds of problems
using this idea of filters and the
generalization to multi filters that
will lead to sort of an obstacle making
it hard to get the kinds of errors that
we want and to overcome that we're going
to need to make use of higher degree
information and I'll talk a little bit
how to do that and if there's time we'll
then go on and talk about an application
to learning mixtures of spherical
gaussians so the beginning with let's
start with this pretty simple problem
there's some gaussian G + RN say it's
known to have identity covariance matrix
but the mean is unknown and you're say
given a bunch of independent samples
from the Skousen and would like to learn
an approximation to me now this is a
pretty classic problem in statistics um
it's sort of well understood that if you
let you have to be the sample mean then
this is a pretty good estimator and in
fact the error is something like oh of
square root and over em with M samples
and this goes to zero as your number of
samples goes to infinity which is about
the best you can hope for okay let's
make our lives more difficult again we
have this Gaussian with an unknown mean
but instead of getting samples just from
the Gaussian there's some other
distribution X that returns a Gaussian
sample with probability 1 minus Epsilon
but with epsilon probability returns
samples from some other distribution
perhaps an adversary Li chosen error
distribution now once again you're given
a bunch of independent samples this time
from X and you'd like to learn an
approximation to the true mean now this
problem is substantially more difficult
so chewkey and what the 60s are 7
these I think gave what amounts to an
exponential time algorithm to get oh of
Epsilon error and it's not hard to show
that in terms of error rate that's
information theoretically optimal at
least up to constants and there have
been various their various polynomial
time algorithms that give arrow of
epsilon square root of n but for a long
time these were sort of the only types
of algorithms known exponential time or
bad error this was fixed only a couple
of years ago where a big paper including
these people gave a polynomial time
algorithm that actually got down to o of
epsilon square root log 1 over epsilon
error and this works against the
slightly stronger error model um and but
you know it's almost the best possible
error and it works in polynomial time
which is good and so this version of the
problem is nearly resolved especially
because a more recent paper by I think
exactly the same authors gave a
polynomial time algorithm that in this
particular error model gets the error
down to O of Epsilon so there's been
substantial recent work on robust
statistics on this and sort of similar
problems and well that's the easy
version ok let's make things more
difficult
so again Gaussian with an unknown mean
but now instead of having just epsilon
error we're going to add a lot of it so
we have a distribution X that with some
small alpha probability returns good
samples from our Gaussian but otherwise
with 1 minus alpha probability return
samples from our error distribution once
again we have a bunch of independent
samples from X and we'd like to learn an
approximation to me now as I've stated
it this problem is actually information
theoretically impossible
because if our distribution X was just a
mixture of gaussians then even if your
algorithm learned the distribution X
exact
which is the most you could hope to do
from samples it would still have no way
to know which of these component
gaussians was the real G and therefore
if they have means that are far apart
from each other there's no one
hypothesis you can give that with high
probability gives you a good
approximation to the true mean so to
make this all possible we're going to
want to relax our requirements a little
bit so we're going to try to do list
Dakota we're going to allow our
algorithm to return several hypotheses
may be some polynomial list or something
like that with only to guarantee that at
least one of these hypotheses that we
returned is close to the actual mean of
course yeah in the previous work what an
epsilon representative epsilon
represented the error rate and that was
considered to be small here alpha is
representing the non error rate which
were considering to be so okay so this
sort of robust list the coding problem
it was originally studied by a paper of
Steinhart Charikar and valiant of last
year and what they gave is a polynomial
time algorithm using some convex
programming techniques it returns
o of 1 and alpha many hypotheses and got
error about alpha to the minus 1/2 now
this it turns out is not the best but
before we get into too much detail about
how to solve this problem we should
first ask ourselves what kind of errors
are actually information theoretically
achievable so that we don't set our
sights too high and in particular you
can prove some reasonable lower bounds
on the final errors that you expect to
get because well what happens if you
have maybe a standard Gaussian now what
you can do is you can sort of if you
only need to hide something sort of an
alpha mask AO seen under this if you
Center this other Gaussian distance you
know square root log 1 over alpha over
some large constant away from the middle
you can nearly hide it under this large
Gaussian basically because the Gaussian
heíd is a lot shorter and eventually the
tails sort of stick out a little bit
beyond where they should but there's
very little probability mass in those
tails once you get far enough out and in
particular if we just add a little bit
of probability mass to X to cover up
some of those extra tails we can hide
something like alpha to the minus Omega
of C such many such gaussians that are
sort of all pretty far apart from each
other in particular this gives us a
lower bound there's no algorithm that
returns only polynomial and one over
alpha many hypotheses oh sorry is there
question closest I mean well I mean C is
it really constant here I mean you can
think of it C as getting large slowly
you should think of C as being sort of
an arbitrarily large constant maybe and
so what I'm saying is that as the
denominator gets arbitrarily large the
exponent gets arbitrarily large as well
okay so the proposition is that there's
no algorithm that returns only
polynomial and 1 over alpha many
hypotheses so that with probability at
least 2/3 guarantees that one of the
hypotheses is little o of root 1 and
alpha from the true mean and the counter
example is just sort of exactly what I
said you build this X you start with
your standard Gaussian you add this tiny
bit of extra tails that allows you to
hide this super polynomial and many
number of gaussians where the two of
them any two of them there means are
separated by about square root log 1
over alpha and if your algorithm doesn't
have there's no way your algorithm can
tell which of these sort of hidden
gaussians is the real one and so unless
you're willing to return something like
one hypothesis for each of these
gaussians or are allowing error of
square root log 1 over alpha there's
nothing you can do other than return a
super polynomial number biases yeah
so they mentioned um this I guess
assumes that the dimension is big enough
but the dimension probably only needs to
be something like log 1 over alpha for
this to work out phase fixed and the
dimension grows and to high more and
more hypotheses um well you might be
able to I didn't see an easy way to
manage that um but but that seems very
plausible
do you have any directions work divided
your I dream cluster you you have more
directions of where to hide your
imposter the problem is that I mean the
construction at least that I'm doing
here I need to allocate a little bit of
extra mass to act to like cover up the
tail of each imposter and that that
limits the number of imposters that I
can have in a way that that having more
dimensions to hide them and doesn't
really fix um but like if instead you
assume that like you didn't need the
full Gauss in there it just needed to be
most of the mass of the Gaussian then
you could hide exponential and and many
Impostors anyway so this is what we
can't do but it turns out that at least
up to issues of computational efficiency
this is roughly tight so there is an
inefficient algorithm at least that
returns only o of 1 and alpha many
hypotheses sets there with probability
at least 2/3 you're guaranteed at least
one of these hypotheses with an O of
route log 1 over alpha Patroni and um
the way to do this is a little bit
interesting so um what you can do is you
can sort of let H be the set of all
possible points X that could reasonably
be the correct me and for that what do I
mean well there should be a set of
points S sub X that sort of correspond
to the good samples and it should be
large consist of at least an alpha over
two fraction of all the samples and also
it should be concentrated about X
students are well concentrated about
their means and in particular this means
that say if we look at any direction
about the mean at most an alpha over ten
fraction of the points from SX are
further than two log of one over alpha
from X in that direction and so
basically we've got good tail bounds in
any direction from the set of points
centered at X and you should note that
with high probability the true mean is
in this set of hypotheses where the set
of points is just the set of good
samples now of course this doesn't work
because this set H is going to be
infinite in size and that's too many
hypotheses um but there's a not bad
solution to this the idea is we're going
to cover the set H with a small number
of balls and so we can just return the
set of centers to those bowls and the
true mean will be close to one of them
will be inside one of those so the lemma
that we want here is that there's a set
there are three that there is no set of
five over alpha elements of H that are
pairwise separated by more than four
root log 1 over alpha and this lemma
will immediately imply our cover because
we can just take a maximal set of
elements of H that are pairwise
separated by 4 root log 1 over alpha
this set has to be small by the lemma
and furthermore because it's a maximal
set every element of H including the
true mean has to be within 4 root log 1
over alpha of one of these hypotheses ok
so how do we prove this lemma well the
idea is to look at overlaps between
these good sets so in particular the
claim is that if x and y are far away
these sets S sub X and X sub y that are
concentrated about the two of them have
to have small overlap and in particular
this is going to allow us to say that we
have many X's that are all pairwise
separated we'll just have to have too
many points allocated to all of these
sets and so the first lemma is that if x
and y are set
by more than four root log 1 over alpha
the size of the intersection of xx and
XY is it most alpha over 10 times the
sum of the sizes of these two cents and
the proof is pretty easy B remember that
one of the properties of these sets was
that they were well concentrated about
the point they were centered at when
projected along any line so what we're
going to do is going to project along
the line separating the mean the two
means x and y and we know that all but a
tiny fraction of the points and S sub X
have to be closer to X than Y along this
line and all with a tiny fraction of the
points in s sebuah have to be closer to
Y than X and therefore any points in the
intersection need to correspond either
to a point in X that was that's X that
was actually closer to Y or a point in
sy that was actually closer to X and
both of those sets are small
so once we have this overlap lemma
there's a pretty simple counting
argument if we have a bunch of points x1
through XM and H that are pairwise
separated by this for root log 1 over
alpha therefore if we look at the size
of the union of these sets well by
approximate inclusion exclusion this is
at least the sum of the sizes of the
sets minus the sum of the sizes of the
pairwise overlaps and that's you know
this alpha over 10 size of SX ice plus
size of sxj but now sort of combining
terms this is going to give us the size
of SX I times 1 minus m alpha over 10 or
something like that from the overlaps
and this is at least something like M
times alpha over 2 size of s times 1
minus m alpha over 10 and if M is say 5
over alpha this is going to be more than
the size of s more than the total number
of samples and this of course is a
contradiction because this union is
contained in s and so I mean this
completes the proof that we at least
information theoretically can can learn
a true means error over log now there
are a few notes about this the firstly
is that we don't really need these
things to be Gaussian if we know that
the good samples are coming from some
distribution where the tails are such
that at most of what alpha over 10
fraction of the points are more than T
away from the true mean in any direction
then we can return o of 1 alpha many
hypotheses with error guaranteed to be o
of T and so if you've got something
other than the Gaussian with worse tail
bounds you can just use that secondly
there is a sort of effective version of
this argument which says that well maybe
I can't generate this infinite set of
hypotheses and deal with it but if you
gave me some set of our
the C's age and guaranteed to me that at
least one of these hypotheses was within
our of the true mean I can cut that set
down to a set of only of 1 and alpha
many hypotheses with error oh of our
plus law of 1 over alpha and I can do
that in polynomial time and the basic
idea is that nor for this argument to
work I only need this concentration to
work in directions along differences
between x and y where x and y are in my
set and since they're only a reasonable
number of those I can just use linear
programming to see which for which of
these you know sets act for which of
these hypotheses X is there a set SX
that has the appropriate concentration
in all of the relevant directions alpha
is the rate of good samples this is all
dimension independent the dimension of
the space is n which doesn't appear
anywhere here so yeah I can get these
error bounds independent of the
dimension that I'm working in of course
I will need dimension dependent factors
in the number of samples and the runtime
of this algorithm but if we're just
caring about the error rates then then
there's no dependents so yeah so what I
can do is I can use them in your program
to sort of find which guys have these
sets SX and then once I have that by
sort of the same lemma I can cover the
set of those hypotheses with a small
number of balls and I can do that
perfectly reasonable okay so it is
summary what we have is that Steinhardt
Charikar in thousand gives an algorithm
that it Taine's o tilde of alpha to the
minus 1/2 error but information
theoretically we know we can see receive
square root log 1 over alpha error so
the natural question to ask is what sort
of error is achievable efficient can we
do better than this alpha to the minus
1/2 can we even get down to square
love one of Ralph okay so let's actually
start talking about algorithms and for
this section I'll start by talking about
our basic techniques which are filters
through the generalization which we call
multi filters but these things run into
an obstacle when you're trying to you
error better than about alpha to the
minus 1/2 and it's here around this
obstacle there's an idea of looking at
sort of higher degree moments and I'll
talk about that and there's in
particular a real problem sort of
controlling variances of things that
requires a lot of technical detail that
I'll touch on at least a little bit but
we'll see I guess ok so let's go back
and sort of look at these problems from
the beginning instead of increasing
order of complexity so for the non
robust version of the algorithm we just
use the sample mean mu hat and we're
good now to the model of the robust
problem we'd like to use the sample mean
but of course there's a problem and a
few bad samples if they are very very
far from the true mean they can actually
seriously corrupt the sample so we're
going to need a way around that and in
particular we're going to want to have a
way to certify that the sample mean is
actually close to the true mean but it
turns out that there's a good way to do
this because if it were not the case
that the sample mean and true mean we're
close they'd have to be some direction
in which they're far apart some unit
vector V such that V dot the difference
is large and in order for a small
fraction of errors to change the mean in
some direction by a lot that actually
requires that these small fraction of
errors contribute a lot to the variance
in that direction so that's going to
mean that the variance of V dot X is
large and we can detect this we can
compute the covariance matrix and see
are there any directions in which the
variance is larger than it should be now
what do we do when we find these large
directions of large variance we know
that they might be causing problems but
we need to we need to actually do some
thing about it if they are but if V dot
X is large what that has to mean is
because the Gaussian is so well
concentrated then the only way you can
add a small number of errors to increase
the variance by a lot is by making them
sort of pretty extreme outliers so what
you can do is you can project on to this
V direction and it'll have to be the
case that there are a bunch of sample
points that are pretty far out from the
mean and just by sort of inspecting
things you should be able to find a
threshold we're beyond which well maybe
you can't say that everything beyond
that threshold is a bad point because of
course some of your good points will be
very very far from the truth but you can
at least say that most of the points
that you're throwing out are going to be
bad samples and so this gives us a
pretty clean algorithm what you do is
you take a set s of samples you compute
the empirical covariance matrix now if
the largest eigen value of this matrix
is small that certifies that your sample
mean is a good approximation to the true
mean
so you just return that otherwise what
you do is you project onto this
direction you use that to create a
filter you apply this to your sample set
so you throw away everything beyond this
threshold this cleans off your set of
samples and then you just go back to
step two and repeat this and the
analysis at least at a high level is
pretty easy every iteration of this
algorithm either makes your sample set
sort of closer to the set of good
samples it either produces a cleaner
sample or it returns an answer that is
certifiably accurate and so it'll keep
on cleaning up your sample set until it
can't clean it up anymore and then it
will return an accurate answer and then
you're done
okay so that was the moderately robust
case what happens in the very robust
case now we're only a small fraction of
our samples are good well most of these
ideas still generalize the natural way
but there's one major problem we try and
implement the filter and that's the
phone we found a large eigenvalue we've
projected all of our samples onto that
direction we now need to sort these into
good samples and bad samples but
unfortunately you might end up with a
distribution like this and there are
actually many places under this
distribution that we can hide an alpha
mask out soon the problem is an alpha is
more than a half than like most of the
samples are good so like the median of
your samples has to be close to the mean
of your Gaussian but when you only with
a small number there are a bunch of
bumps any of which could hide your
Gaussian and so we can't just say well
here's a line everything you know
everything to the right of this line has
to be bad because I mean our we don't
know where the good samples are located
so to fix this what we're going to do is
instead of just splitting into good
samples and bad samples we're going to
sort of bifurcate we're gonna split our
samples into two sets of points or maybe
more and we're going to want to have the
guarantee that at least one of these
sets of points contains a better
fraction of good samples than our
original set and so maybe one of these
sets of points throughout all of our
good samples and then we're just getting
garbage when we analyze it but at least
one of the sets if we keep analyzing it
will continue to give us good results
and then for somewhat technical reasons
since we're sort of having an explosion
and the number of sets that we're
dealing with we want to make sure this
doesn't get too bad so we're going to
guarantee for example that the sum of
the squares of the sizes of these new
sets of samples that we end up with is
it most the squared size of the original
okay and so how do we know that we can
do this well the analysis splits into
two cases in case one almost all of the
samples lie in the same small interval
and in case two they don't and in
particular what that means there are two
clusters of samples that are very far
away from each other so case one if
there is some interval I that contains
say all but an alpha 3 over 3 fraction
of our samples then we can actually say
that with high probability the true mean
is in this interval I and in particular
that means that all but a tiny fraction
of our good samples are within about
square root log 1 over alpha of I after
you've projected them onto this line and
in particular that means that unless the
variance in this direction is also
similarly small unless it's something
like oh of length of I squared plus log
1 over alpha then it's going to be the
case that we can find the filter that
will throw I a bunch of bad samples it's
sort of that are too far from the
interval and at most an alpha squared
fraction say of the removed samples will
be good samples and so in this case it
looks a lot like our old filter we just
throw on a bunch of samples almost all
of which are bad and we've cleaned
things up the other case is a little bit
more difficult suppose that there is no
such interval lock or in other words
sort of by adjustment we can find an
interval I of about the same length
where there's at least an alpha over 6
fraction of our samples on either side
of it so there are lots of samples out
on the tails on either side maybe we
can't just find a single interval where
we can guarantee that the mean is in
that interval but we can do something
else now so for some value of x we're
going to pick two sets s 1 is going to
be the set of samples that are less than
or equal to say X plus 10 root log 1
over alpha and s 2 is going to be the
set of samples that are bigger than or
equal to X minus 10
log went around and these these have
some overlap and I play the overlap is
enough that all but that that if we at
least pick the correct one of these s1
or s2 all that a tiny fraction of the
removed samples are going to be Beth in
particular if the true mean is bigger
than or equal to asks all but a tiny
fraction of our samples are in s2 and if
the true mean is less than or equal to X
all that a tiny fraction of our samples
are in x1 and as long as X was picked to
be somewhere in this interval we've
thrown a fair number of bad samples on
the on the wrong side of it and so in
this case you know we're guaranteed that
one of these sets had this property that
should have cleaned up our set it
throughout almost only bad samples
however there was this extra technical
condition that we needed to sort of
guarantee that we don't just end up with
an explosion of tons of sets that we're
dealing with we wanted the sum of the
squares of the sizes of these sets to
not be bigger than the squared size of
the original so how do we analyze that
let's let f of X be the fraction of our
samples that are less than or equal to X
so what we want is we want some x in our
interval such that one minus f of x
squared plus f of X plus xx root log 1
over alpha squared is less than or equal
to 1 this basically says that if we
looked at the integral of everything
bigger than or equal to X and everything
less than or equal to X plus 20 root log
that that those sets work and well I
mean this doesn't necessarily happen but
if it fails it's going to have to be the
case that f of X plus 20 root log is
much much bigger than the square root of
f of X and this very quickly becomes a
problem if our interval is long because
it's going to be fine unless well I mean
advic the end of the interval was
already alpha or alpha over 6 or
something
and so this would say that well we're
going to be fine unless f of X plus 20
root log is at least root alpha and then
f of X plus 40 root log is at least
alpha to the 1/4 and f of X plus 60 root
logs at least alpha to the 1/8 and so on
and so forth and after we've moved about
log log 1 over alpha times square root
log 1 over alpha away from the end point
suddenly we're demanding that almost all
of the samples are on that side of the
interval and if our interval is too long
this this can't possibly happen
essentially and in particular unless our
interval is shorter than square root log
of 1 over alpha times log log 1 over
alpha we can always find an appropriate
X such that these two sets exist ok so
what can we say we can create either a
filter or a multi filter that will allow
us to make progress as long as one of
the following two wholes either there is
no interval of length I of you know
square root log whatever alpha log log 1
over alpha that contains all but an
alpha over 3 fraction of samples or
there is an interval of AI of that
length that contains all but an alpha
over 3 fraction of samples and the
variance is something like Omega of I
squared
I think particular that means that as
long as the variance in some direction
is more than a sufficient multiple of
with a little bit of improvement to this
argument can actually get down to log 1
over alpha if there's a direction with
that variance then we can actually find
these sets we can find at most two sets
si such that for at least one of these
sets we've at most an alpha squared
fraction of the points that we threw out
we're good and furthermore the sum of
the squares of the sizes of these sets
is at most the squared size of the
origin and finally this allows us to
build our multi filter so what we're
going to do is we're going to instead of
maintaining one set of samples we're
going to maintain
several of them for each eye we're going
to compute an empirical covariance
matrix now if some empirical covariance
matrix has a large eigenvalue we're
going to project we're going to create a
multi filter we're going to apply it
perhaps breaking that set into two new
sets and then we're going to go back to
step two and we're just going to repeat
this until everything has small
eigenvalues and then we're Don run or
just return the list of all the sample
means of all of these sets yeah
[Music]
distribution options but much smaller
weight you just retain all of them what
happens if our error distribution has
Gauss is a smaller width and we retain
all of them well the point is that if we
retain all of them that means that our
covariance matrix is going to have to be
small and what we'll see in a bit is
that your covariance matrix is small and
you contain almost all of the good
samples then that's going to imply that
the sample mean has to be at least
reasonably close to the true mean and so
sort of you can add errors that this
thing doesn't detect but the only way
you can do that is by adding errors that
don't really mess up the sample mean by
too much okay but let's look at the
analysis so the point is that at every
step of this at least one of these sets
that we're working with will have at
least an alpha fraction of good samples
in fact it'll be a lot better in terms
of good samples than we started with and
secondly it'll always be the case the
sum of the squares of the sizes of these
sets is at most the squared size of the
original set and this is mostly useful
to say that we'll never have more than a
polynomial number of these sets so we'll
never return more than a polynomial
number of hypotheses and it will not
won't take more than polynomial time
okay but when we return an answer what
happens well if we have some aside has
an alpha fraction of good samples and
it's covariance matrix has no large
eigenvalues what does that mean
well for any unit vector log 1 over
alpha is much bigger than the variance
of the set in that direction and that's
going to be at least alpha times V dot
the difference between the means in that
squared and in particular that's is in
every direction the difference between
the means is of something like outputs
the minus 1/2 times square root log
whatever alpha and particularly that
gives us a bound on the error between
them and so we'll we've managed to
reconstruct this o tilde of alpha to the
minus 1/2 from Steinhardt Charikar and
valent but we'll hopefully be able to
take these techniques and push them a
little bit further
unfortunately there'll actually a major
obstacle for these techniques that about
alpha to the minus 1/2 because you can
actually have error as much as alpha to
the minus 1/2 and still have well
controlled variance because maybe what
we have is we've gotten you know some
big cluster of points near some mean and
then our good points are this tiny alpha
fractional points somewhat displaced
from that mean our good points though
can be displaced by as much as alpha to
the minus 1/2 before they contribute
more than 1 those are the variance in
that direction and so if we're willing
to live with variances as large as 1 or
even log 1 over alpha then we certainly
we can't detect the fact that our good
samples are off by alpha to the minus
1/2 ok so how do we deal with this
basically the problem that we're running
into is that these bounds that we saw on
second moments are not enough to ensure
the kind of concentration that we want
we want to make sure that all of our
points and thus our good points are sort
of close to the sample mean
but our bounds are on our concentration
bounds aren't good enough these we're
only using second moments well there's
an obvious fix for that let's use higher
moments and when you start looking at
this this looks nice it says well so if
it were the case
for all unit vectors V they say 2d
central moment in the V Direction was o
of 1 well that would tell us that this
one was much bigger than alpha times the
2d 'the moment of the error between the
true mean and sample mean in that
direction and I would say the mean error
between the true mean and sample mean is
all of output to the minus 1 and 2d
which is great this I mean we set it all
to the minus 1 and chewing it alpha to
the minus 1 in 4 6 8 whenever we can get
something pretty good unfortunately get
sort of arranging for this to be the
case is actually hard it's
computationally intractable to determine
whether or not there is a unit vector V
such that the two deep central moments
in the V Direction is large and whenever
D is bigger than 1 and since we can't
solve this problem we can't know whether
or not our deep central moments are to
need central moments are bounded or not
and that's going to be an issue now the
basic idea for how to fix this is to
look at a relaxation of this problem
that we actually can solve and there are
a bunch of sort of contemporaneous works
that do the relaxation by sort of
instead of you know actually just can
you find a V for this instead they say
is there a sum of squares proof that are
higher that our central moments are
bounded and well if you could find the
sum of squares proof you're good and if
you can't find the sum of squares proof
well hopefully you can use that to show
something else now in this talk we went
through on a slightly different idea the
idea is to relax in a different way
we're going to do is see is there any
degree D polynomial where the
expectation of P squared is much larger
than it should be
okay and in particular if we take P to
be V dot X raised to the D will be will
be good so what's the basic idea we're
going to determine whether or not there
is a degree D polynomial P where the
expectation of P of s squared is
substantially larger than the
expectation of P of a Gaussian at our
sample mean squared and this looks
really great it's an eigenvalue
computation so we can do it if it's not
true then we get our bounds the error
between mu and the sample mean is au
tilde of alpha to the minus 1 and too
deep and if there is such a P we could
hope to create some kind of a multi
filter and well what you'd like to be
able to say is well the variance of P of
X is larger than it should be so we're
just going to look at the values of P n
we're gonna find the outliers we're
going to throw them away or maybe we're
going to take two overlapping sets and
do the same sort of thing
and this sounds like it should work but
there's a really annoying technical
difficulty which is that the variance of
P of G might actually be large and one
thing that we used in the degree one
case is if you have a linear function
the variance of that linear function of
your Gaussian doesn't depend on the mean
of the Gaussian however with even degree
two polynomials that's no longer the
case and we don't know the mean of G we
don't know the mean of the variance and
dealing with that proves to be pretty
difficult now I'm told that I'm short on
time so I'm going to probably skip a lot
of this but what is the very basic idea
if we find we would like to be able to
verify basically that the expectation of
the square of our polynomial isn't too
big and the expectation of P squared of
our Gaussian is some polynomial Q of MU
where Q is some polynomial in the true
mean mu and the thing that allows us to
get this to work is
this in turn equals the expectation of
our of G one through G to D where R is a
multi linear polynomial and these G is
are independent copies of G and what
makes this work more or less is that if
this is large that's a thing we can
actually detect because that should say
that that if we take a bunch of
independent samples from X and evaluate
R at those we should get values of that
that are too big and so that's the thing
at least that we can see and we'll
basically because R is multi linear we
can treat it in sort of a linear
polynomial in each coordinate and if
this is returning values that are bigger
than they should be
we can then use that to find a linear
function that's returning values that
are bigger than they should be and that
was sort of exactly the thing that
allows us to produce a filter so again
I'm gonna skip a lot of this because
it's technical and I don't have time
bomb but in the end basically we we need
a number of samples that's something
like poly n to the D over alpha and the
run time is a little bit more than that
because we need to check for some of
these events that with probability alpha
to the to D and so our run time is
polynomial in the number of samples and
alpha to the minus T but the feeling is
we have an algorithm runs in this sort
of reasonable amount of time and samples
and with high probability returns a list
of all of 1-alpha many hypotheses so
that with high probability at least one
of them is within a sub D of alpha to
the minus 1 into D of the true mean now
you can actually do this for D being
super constant we show that in
quasi-polynomial time and samples you
can actually get this down to poly log
error and we don't have this quite
worked out in the paper but we think
with a slightly sharper analysis you can
actually get the arrow down to the
information theoretically optimal of
square root log okay um so um in fact if
you're looking at this sort of list
decoding result a
quantitatively tight at least for
statistical query algorithms and ileus
should talk a lot more about these a
little later in the day but the theorem
is that you have any statistical query
list decoding algorithm that with at
least 2/3 probability returns list of
hypotheses at least one of which is
close with and then alpha to the minus 1
and D of the mean it must do one of the
following it must either return
exponentially many hypotheses perform
exponentially many queries which is
basically the analog for spending
exponential runtime or return queries or
with accuracy ends the minus Omega D
which is morally a stand-in for take
more than n to the D samples and so I
mean this is a restricted computational
model but at least morally speaking we
expect that these bounds that we have
are tight if you want to do get better
error you either need to take as many
samples as we do return exponentially
many hypotheses or spend exponential run
time and well I'm pretty much out of
time I I will say that there's a very
nice application of this to learning
mixtures of spherical gaussians so here
there are no errors but you have a
mixture of gaussians and this is very
nice because well if you just run our
list decoding algorithm on a mixture of
gaussians you can simultaneously think
of this distribution as a noisy version
of each component gaussian and so you're
guaranteed that you have for each
gaussian at least one hypothesis as
close to the mean of that component and
if furthermore you assume that the
pairwise means are reasonably well
separated from each other separated by
about more than the error in our list
decoding algorithm then having these
hypotheses actually allows you to do
clustering in a very natural way just
sort of round sample to the nearest
hypothesis and cluster them together
naturally and this'll actually allows
you to recover the original components
and so the result is that if the means
of your components have separations
something like k to the one and to D
then this algorithm takes something like
polynomial and N and D K to the D
samples runs in polynomial time then
returns accurate approximations to the
means of the components and I'll say a
few things one sort of before this and
the bunch of contemporaneous works came
out the best that was known is that you
could do this with K to the 1/4
separation and so we can get it you know
K to the Delta separation for any
arbitrarily small Delta and in fact once
again if you are willing to spend poly
logarithm story quasi-polynomial time
and samples you can get this down to
poly logarithmic or maybe even square
root log K separation beyond square root
log K separation there are information
theoretic reasons why you can't
approximate the means anymore
and well okay in conclusion so what we
have here is we've got a robust list
decoding algorithm with substantially
better error than had been known before
it has this nice application to learning
mixtures of spherical gaussians with K
to the Delta separation and a few open
questions to look at one is how much can
the Gaussian this assumption be relaxed
in this work I very at least our
techniques are so the very heavily
dependent on facts about higher degree
polynomials of gaussians the sum of
squares techniques can relax this
somewhat it'd be interesting to see if
you can do better than that
also can you do better for trying to
learn mixtures of gaussians than you can
for list decoding so we know that if you
can do list decoding you can use that to
learn mixtures but we don't have any
reason we don't know that that sort of
these are equivalent problems may be
learning mixtures is easier maybe you
can do in polynomial time even with only
square root log separation that'd be
interesting also if you don't care about
actually learning the individual me
maybe you can try to find better
algorithms for density estimations here
these sort of information theoretic
lower bounds don't even apply and you
could hope that you could do density
estimation for this mixture of gaussians
with without any separation assumptions
um but again nobody knows how to do that
okay that's all I had to say are there
any questions so we have time for one
question what about next speaker yeah I
mentioned an extra dozen remain
efficiently that's it yeah efficiently
yeah if you want doing it efficiently
that's not hard
I'm missing my mouse
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]